[موسيقى]
خلال العصور القديمه لم يكن لدى الانسان
اجهزه لعد الاغنام والمحاصيل وغيرهما
باستثناء اصابع يديه وقدميه لكن العالم
اليوم نجح في ابتكار اشكال لا محدوده من
الالات الحاسبه وتطويرها بطريقه لا تغنيك
عن العد فحسب بل وعن تعلم الكثير من علوم
الرياضيات الصعبه كالتكامل والتفاضل
وغيرهما فكيف حدث ذلك في العام 2500 قبل
الميلاد تقريبا استخدم السومريون اول اداه
عرفت تاريخيا لاجراء الحسابات الرياضيه
وكانت تسمى المعداد او العداد وهي عباره
عن جدول من الاعمده المتتاليه مع الخرز او
الاحجار المصفوفه معا التي يمكن من خلالها
القيام بالجمع او الطرح كذلك قامت حضارات
اخرى باتباع طرق مشابهه للعد فالصينيون
مثلا رص الخرز على سلك اطار من الخيزران
واستخدموه للعد ولكن هذه الادوات لم تكن
مجديه في الضرب او القسمه بين القرنين
الخامس عشر والثامنه عشر شهدت انحاء من
اوروبا والشرق الاوسط ولاده ادوات حسابيه
جديده كان اغلبها يعتمد على لوح مزود
بسلسله من الارقام المرتبه فوق اعمده
خشبيه او معدنيه او ورقيه يتم ترتيبها
بطريقه معينه لتجميع الارقام واجراء
العمليات الحسابيه لكن الاداه الاشهر جاءت
بامضاء عالم الرياضيات والمخترع
الاسكتلندي جون نابيير حيث استخدم مجموعه
من القضبان لحساب المضاعفات في عام
1614 تقريبا
سميت هذه الطريقه الحساب بالقضبان حيث
تكونت من العظام وهي قضبان رفيعه منقوشه
بجداول الضرب وضعت داخل صندوق بطريقه
افقيه احترافيه ساعدت على قراءه جداول
الضرب مكانت هذه الاداه التي عرفت باسم
عظام الابيار في الحسابات الشخص القادره
على القيام بالحسابات الذهنيه لكنها لم
تكن تعد حاسبه حقيقيه اول حاسبه حقيقيه
كانت من تطوير عالم الرياضيات الفرنسي
الذي استنبط مبدا عملها من مبدا عمل
الساعه وكان ذلك في عام
1642 حيث ابتكر اله تقوم باجراء العمليات
الحسابيه التي كان يعتقد سابقا انها
مستحيله اخترع باسكال الاله لوالده الذي
كان يعمل جابا للضرائب وصنع منها نحو 50
على مدى السنوات العشر اللاحقه
في وقت لاحق من القرن السابع عشر ابتكر
غوت فريد ويلهم اله اكثر تقدما ثم توالت
ابتكارات الات الحساب الميكانيكيه حيث
ابتكرت توماس ديكورمر في منتصف القرن
التاسع عشر اله ميكانيكيه اسهل في الانتاج
لكنها كانت كبيره جدا وضخمه مقارنه مع ما
هو موجود اليوم في العقود الاولى من القرن
العشرين تم تطوير الات اكثر تقدما كان
بعضها يعمل بالمفتاح والبعض الاخر يحتاج
الى اسطوانه دواره لادخال المبالغ في ثقوب
بلوحه المفاتيح وبعد ذلك يتم تدوير
الاسطوانه بواسطه محرك كهربائي في عام
1945 عرف العالم اول اله حاسبه ميكانيكيه
محموله من تصميم
وانتجت منها كميات كبيره حتى عام 1970
اخترعت شركه في اليابان اول اله حاسبه
رقميه للجيب لاحقا قامت الشركات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مثل تكساس
بتطوير تصميم الجهاز الياباني وتحسينه من
خلال انشاء الالات الحاسبه الرسوميه التي
نعرفها اليوم
بحلول اواخر القرن العشرين تم تصميم
العديد من الالات الحاسبه المتخصصه مع
قدرات متطوره للقيام باكثر من 5000 خطوه
ولم تعد بحاجه الى حملها في جيبك حيث اصبح
بامكانك اقتناؤها على شكل برنامج في
حاسوبك او هاتفك الذكي